[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and Randall Chamblee Golf Channel
analyst joining us on the program how
surprised if you are surprised that
Brooks koepka is making some headlines
you know it was tough to sort of as I
was trying to make a pick for the week
it was tough to get your arms around how
any of the live guys were playing
because
there's really no data you know it's
hard to follow those there's no game
stories written about those events you
try to watch a little bit of it I did
but the competition you know about half
that Field's not really world class so
it was hard to sort of guess how he was
playing but after about four or five
holes yesterday it wasn't so hard uh
nobody hit their irons better than
Brooks kepta yesterday matter of fact
Peter made a pot yesterday they had a
four or five shot lead after yesterday's
round and then he's doing the same thing
today uh you know he made some nice
putts early in his round but he just as
you just said he just Eagle the eighth
to take a three shot lead if he keeps
hitting the ball the way he's hitting it
right now he could just run away and
hide
I just talked to Jim Nance I said what
kind of storyline is the live tour what
kind of storyline can it be coming up
this weekend he said well it's it's
about the Masters and it'll probably
stay just about the Masters now he's
saying that as the host of CBS but you
not afraid to give an opinion on this
how big a story would that be on Sunday
if they live tour player is there in the
final grouping yeah I mean obviously the
Masters it will be about the competition
but the rest of the golf world will
definitely be looking at a live player
and a PGA Tour player and and it will
certainly pump up the ratings here I
mean if it goes again if it's Brooks
kepka coming down with John ROM I can't
imagine a better scenario from a sports
you know a sports wide concept you know
the rest of the gulf world would be
talking about this is a referendum on
live whether they want to call it that
or not and this is a competition between
live and the PTA tour uh there's just no
denying that I understand obviously at
Augusta National they want to keep it
about the competition and that won't
come up in The Telecast I mean if it
does it'll come up softly or
peripherally or organically but they
won't dwell on it but the rest of the
golf world will certainly be paying
attention to it I would say Rory
against kepco would be better than ROM
versus Kevin no doubt I would have said
Rory but Rory shot even par yesterday
he's gonna have to shoot 64 to get back
65 64 to get back in this thing today
because it's not just how many it's just
not that he was seven back it's the
players that shot the scores in front of
Rory there there's so many good players
who played great yesterday and the
course is too soft to uh for many of
them to come back
well the weather now plays a role how
big a role is weather going to be it's
going to get windy and one of the things
I think that's more interesting Dan is
this week plays out is that the way the
wind is going to come
is going to make this golf course play
harder than you know it's the hardest
win because it's a it's a Northeast wind
which means
seven holes that work right to left will
have a left to right wind so you're
going to stand on that t and if you're
if your predominant shot is just a fade
and you're not capable of drawing it
into the wind
it's going to be very difficult to hit
those t-shots in the Fairway even as
soft as it is and so Brooks kepka
primarily plays a fade so does John ROM
so you know you look at a Scotty
shuffler who hit the ball almost as well
as those two guys and didn't make too
many pots yesterday and you figure you
know he's comfortable working in both
directions so that's when this golf
course or this tournament becomes more
interesting
what do you make of Tiger's comments
where he was in constant pain yesterday
and and we both know that that's not a
flat course and you know you could see
where that could have an impact on Tiger
but it almost felt like you know he's
ready to ride off into the sunset when
it comes to playing Augusta yeah I think
Fred Couples you know I love Fred he
just nailed it the other day he was like
yeah he can hit the shots but can he get
around this place it's the hardest golf
course in the world to walk if you're 25
year olds 25 years old and healthy uh
you know tiger swung as hard as he could
off the 8th T yesterday and his ball
speed was 169.
at the Riviera the Genesis his
tournament early in the Years Ball speed
was 182-3-4
so you know and I other players in his
group I think trying to remember who was
in his group to get their ball speed up
to 181 or 182 there so that to me spoke
volumes about the kind of pain that
tiger was in he was noticeably grimacing
and hobbling and then the shot on 18
that he had yesterday I don't know if
you saw it but that didn't do him any
favors you know one leg into bunker his
right leg his right leg in the bunker
his left leg out and after he hit it all
the weight was on his right leg and he
hopped on it for a bit uh those are the
kind of things that just you know flat
out will hobble him talking to Brando
Chamblee the lead analyst with Golf
Channel trying to understand Phil
Mickelson's place in golf or The Golf
World now where he had a chance to be
Arnold Palmer he had a chance to be the
the golf Ambassador the rest of his
career and then as the story came out he
went to the Champions dinner and he
didn't say anything which to me is
impossible for Phil to sit there did
anybody ask him a question did he did he
just sit there and eat his meal and not
say a word when I heard he didn't say a
word I think maybe Phil said that I
thought that's hard to believe but other
people that were in the room said it's
true he just came in there and I think
out of respect because you know the you
know you've been around Phil I've been
around Phil I mean he knows a lot about
a lot and and he's happy to share it and
uh and look he's entertaining I'll give
him that but I think out of respect for
Scotty and that's you know that's that's
a nice gesture by Phil uh but to your
point if Phil hadn't gone to live if he
hadn't been actively recruiting players
to live and then actively trying to
I would say undermine the PGA Tour I'm
being being kind there
where was Phil going to go you're right
he would have been he would have
ascended to a spot in the booth where he
would have been unbelievable I mean he'd
have been Tony Romo in the booth you
know he'd have been Barkley in the booth
he would have been so good and you know
he'd have made a fortune doing that and
a fortune everything off that off that
he would have ascended to Arnold Palmer
he would have been an honorary starter
at Augusta National he would have ridden
off into the sunset as one of the great
personalities and
caretakers of this game and it's just
sad that he's torpedoed that Legacy
I was told he was going to replace Faldo
this is a couple years ago you know I've
got it on you know I've I've heard that
I mean he was the guy he had done a
little bit I'm sure you saw him in the
PGA Championship in San Francisco where
he got in the booth and he was he was
terrific
you know I mean look feels bright he's
talkative he's not afraid to share his
opinion uh he had I think pretty good
relationships with most everybody he
knows a lot about the golf swing he
could have been the best commentator in
the history of golf and now when you see
him he's a shell of the person that he
used to be
but I mean you know if I gave him a
do-over Brandel yeah a mulligan yeah
what do you think Phil would choose I
think he'd take it I really do I think
he'd take it uh you know let's say it's
true that he left for a couple hundred
million dollars so he would take it and
and stay on the PGA tour he would do it
I think he would I think he would I
think he'd stay on the PGA tour okay you
know if if he did in fact make a couple
hundred million dollars going to live
it wouldn't take you or I a minute to
come up with ways he was going to make
200 million dollars on the PGA tour
commentating you know all of his
endorsements you look at him now none of
those endorsements that he had forever
are present you know he's just got his
team from live and that's it because
everybody everybody bailed on him after
he talked about the atrocities and said
that he could use them as Leverage
help me understand Rory because every
time I watch him I go how does he not
win
you and me both uh I I think Augusta is
is not a great fit for him
uh you know he's he's an amazing golfer
uh and when he's at his best it's it's
you know you think how can anybody beat
him but Augusta has
has several shots there's no matter of
fact there's really only two holes out
there that don't have these types of
shots where you have a if you're a
right-handed golfer a right to left lie
that you need to cut it on so that's a
that's a pretty technically difficult
thing to do and to hit that the best way
you've got to be pretty upright with
your golf swing or you have to sort of
come over the top of it Rory is real
deep and flat with his golf swing he
comes underneath it and when you when
you're coming from the inside and you
hit those Hills it shuts your face down
and so if you remember the shot he hit
yesterday at 13. you drove it around the
corner and he pulled it into the Into
the Bunker left to the green he hits
more of those shots because he swings
deep and comes from the inside then
players who swing upright and get on top
of the plane and that's Scotty Scheffler
and that's Tiger Woods and that's Jordan
Spieth and that's Jack Nicklaus and
Arnold Palmer and Phil Mickelson and the
rest of them uh and so it's just not a
great fit for Roy and having said that
he has played some pretty good golf
around here but he's not he's not played
anywhere near as good as he plays uh uh
weekend and week out on the PGA tour
yeah when when Rory goes left that's
when I know there's there's big trouble
there
I'll leave you with this uh you could
have a major at Pebble you could have
Augusta or you could have the British
Open at St Andrews to go as a fan
I would go to Augusta okay I've never
heard anybody go to Augusta for the
Masters come away and say anything other
than it exceeded their expectations not
that those others don't but the
experience of Augusta is it's a bucket
list item for sure
have fun today as always and please play
nice all right that's it
Randall Chamblee Golf Channel leads
Studio analyst golf Central live from
the Masters surrounds the Masters
Tournament comprehensive Studio coverage
there with uh Rich Lerner Steve Sands
also one of the hosts Mike Tarico as
well we'll take a break your phone calls
are next we're back after this